وبين الرفض المطلق لفكره التبرع بالاعضاء
التزام بفتوى سابقه للشيخ محمد متولي
الشعراوي باعتباره انتهاكا لامانه الجسد
الذي وهبه الله للانسان وقبول الفكره املا
في انقاذ حياه بعض المرضى فان الرغبه في
التبرع بدات في الانتشار في اوساط
المصريين ساعد على ذلك حملات التوعيه التي
يطلقها ناشطون و ازدياد احتياج المرضى
لزراعه اعضاء قد تهم لهم الحياه
اول ما اخذت الخطوه بتاعه ان انا اعمل
اقرار للتبرع بالاعضاء بعد الوفاه اهلي
كانوا تمام معايا جدا ما كانوا سبورت هايل
الصراحه بس كانوا اصحابي دائما عندهم اييي
انت فاضيه لايه ولا ايه يعني انت بتجري في
قضيه مقفوله او قضيه ما لهاش حل اا بس انا
اخذت القرار ان انا مهما سمعت ان اي احد
هاروح واعمل اقرار لان هي بدايه القانون
اللي يتفعل ان يبقى في عدد المتبرعين
بالمجتمع اللي حواليا مختلف يعني اخواتي
همم اخواتي مثلا همم
احترمه عارفين انه دي حاجه عايزاه من زمان
بس مش هتحصل ال- همم الوحيد الاكبر بيبص
لي كده كانه همم
اه ضربت او همم
[موسيقى]
غلبانه الست دي يعني مش عارفه مش فاهمه
حاجه باين انها ولا ايه
في ناس بقت تبص لي انه ممم يعني عايز اركب
التراند في ناس بتبص لي يعني كافره في ناس
بتبصوا لي على انهي واحده في ناس بتبص لي
اني بتحدى ربنا وفي ناس بتبص ليه
الناس عموما كانت
خالص اصلا الكلام في الموضوع ده بيخاف انا
عارف واحده ست لطيفه جدا